victoria et lilly ont été retrouvés dans
des conditions déplorables pour parents
sont morts raison vécu seul dans la
nature pendant au moins cinq ans salut
victorien le fait qu'elle ait survécu
est inexplicable je suis le frère de ton
papa tu te rappelles oncle look dans un
environnement familial aimant victoria
lilly ont une vraie chance de reprendre
une vie normale après tout si non
salut fis je suis un label vous pouvez
m'appeler comme ça où comme vous voulez
ces petites filles sont loin d'être
prêtes à vivre ça et je suis loin d'être
prêtes à vivre ça
avez vous remarqué elle parle au mur
et qu'est ce qu'elles disent ça va
s'arranger je te le promets
certes
j'aimerais que tu m'en disent plus sur
ma main qu'est ce qui ne va pas je te
promets qui va rien m'arriver
tu peux pas faire ça
je crois que quelqu'un via leur rendre
visite
qu'est-ce qu'il ya celui fantôme est une
émotion totalement déformés qui est
condamné à se répéter
matt et malvoyants
ou est elle maintenant
est ce qu'elle est ici dans la maison
abba promise
qui est même à victoria